I'm doing good are you I'm excited like  I feel like this is gonna be a whole lot  of fun  I mean if people's in the area and I  asked yeah why not how are you enjoying  Super Bowl what he shows up in some of  our decisions oh I think the selfie  party my own party is just clubbing in  Atlanta you're out here with you you  know I I knew it was gonna be too hectic  I know the city was gonna be too much  and this is my average I just up there  in LA I'm going back home on Monday so  it's like hey you wanna know something  it's funny because you know you buy so  many clothes for babies and then like  the Couture stuff and the expensive  name-brand stuff you put it on her and  then it's like right away she throws all  she drools or she might crap on it and  she just ends up being in the you know  target outfit you know like Anna target  one see my best pictures and videos of  her is she taking a deal pajamas  [Music]